alors dit moi on pas sortir doit juger
vraiment est ce que tu pourrais faire
draguer auxerre vague et je prends le
salut les copains ça travaille à ces
niveaux draguer au soir de rai uno qui
préfèrent l'art vient de se faire
larguer leurs yeux la dernière fois que
tu as pleuré pour une femme c'était
quand mon grand père mon tout petit mais
très contenue le forum en toi y'a pas
longtemps en ligne et où sa voix sa
guitare pour toi maintenant je pense pas
non plus hein tu dormi ou habille le
jour venu tu pour faire la chose tu
éteins la lumière où tu laisses la
lumière allumée manière je suis mieux
des filiales à muriel sur l'algérie une
expérience homosexuelle
non merci mme c'est jay recours à
l'amour tarifé
tavin l'amour tarifé soto del valle put
quoi
on appelle ça comme c'est vrai est-ce
que sinon on se parle à lui ses missions
ses services publics et des mots qu'on
peut prendre bien sûr pourquoi n'y la
dernière fois c'est quand je prends moi
je vaux risque pas de le dire donc t'as
pas besoin de l'association des
consommateurs de programme il ya 30
millions d'amis le voilà je pars là
dedans mais tu vas voir importants 1